ç aa
moka son escarpins bottes au tennis
leurs composants viennent des quatre
coins du monde sont assemblés en
roumanie ou en asie pour être vendus
dans les riches les occidentaux
on y retrouve sur les podiums des plus
grands défilés et dans les publicités à
gros budget
mais à contre courant de cette
mondialisation effrénée une petite
chaussure est en train de prendre du
galon l'espadrille à milieu du
microcosme parisien de la mode
mauléon en plein coeur du pays basque
capitale de l'espadrille depuis le 19e
siècle
c'est dans ce village que nous avons
rencontré jean-jacques ou ue qui
fabrique ces sandales 100% naturel en
limite au bout du monde il ya beaucoup
de monde qui arrive au bout du monde
mais il est important pour nous de
montrer que nous les aurons encore on
fait des espadrilles on le député c'est
un prétexte mais je trouve que c'est
bien parce que on a souvent l'habitude
de dire que les politiques qui sont sur
notre planète b c'est bien qu'il repose
les pieds sur terre et qui vient de nous
voir
jean lassalle le député de la 4e
circonscription des pyrénées-atlantiques
est donc très attendu cet élu vous le
connaissez il a beaucoup fait parler de
lui en 2006 jean lassalle a gagné son
combat le député udf en grève de la faim
depuis 39 jours est hospitalisé
d'urgence ce matin a obtenu des
garanties
payal ne délocalisera pas sa production
et va même investir dans la vallée
d'aspe épuisé à bout de force le député
était hospitalisée en urgence ce matin
sur demande du médecin de l'assemblée
nationale après cinq semaines de jeunes
il a perdu plus de 20 kg et en 2013
c'est élu atypique s'est encore fait
remarquer pendant huit mois il a fait le
tour du pays à pied afin de recueillir
les préoccupations des français
mais cette fois ci il a souhaité se
concentrer sur sa circonscription
comment allez vous ça va jean-jacques
s'est installé dans son atelier de
mauléon il ya 26 ans à votre part vous
salir super on fait orchestre on y va
depuis il y travaille avec sa femme et
nous on a repris ceux ci avaient daniel
donc daniel c'est ici que le couple
fabrique ses espadrilles dont les
tresses qui composent la semaine est
élaboré avec cette machine
cette machine davantage plus de 90 ans
et c'est un fonctionnement très serré
elle a été modernisée avec un moteur
électrique et autres autrement ça marche
avec des moulins aux résidences
appartenaient à la jeune homme mais on
va voir une chose
l'ingéniosité des gens parce que c'était
des magiciens à l'époque voyez salir
hyper complexe on va on va suivre ce je
repère juste pour dans l'acheminement de
détresse
il ya rien ça fait dix-huit incessants
et qui forment la tresse et on va
occasionner une casse
une panne oui elle est intelligente vous
allez faire vous même à quelques mètres
de tresses près allez-y alors se jouer
maintenant et c'est bien sûr je me suis
malien que de table il nous touche pas
là parce que pour ne pas me faire
embobiner me retrouver sous forme de
très souvent aussi
les outils ont été achetés par le grand
père de l'ancien propriétaire
c'est lui qui a créé l'atelier au début
du 20e siècle
mais moi je ne revienne pas de fait la
demande de la modernité de cette machine
et vous savez c'est tellement simple il
est difficile de trouver mieux alors
difficile d avoir la garde on regarde on
va les entretenir et c'est une sécurité
tu vois aujourd'hui on est un petit peu
d'argent on est certainement déréglé on
est pas mal réglée par le fait qu'on
veut sans un rond mais seulement si tu
sophistiqué a alors qu'on a des choses
qui peuvent très bien me faire le ventre
enfin jacques très attachant j'aime ce
qui fait peur de sa vie de ce qu'il
produit et heureux de du rythme auquel
il vit
enfin il est un ardent et harmonie avec
ce qu'il aime c'est un artiste un
artiste qui année après année a aménagé
un atelier à son image avec dans chaque
recoin une machine d'un autre temps là
je vais vous montrer le moulage de la
tresse alors croyez on a de la tresse ça
c'est la presse pour faire des espaces
dits traditionnels
alors je m'installe je vais vous montrer
après vous en ferez une autre je
commence par le devant je passe au talon
sur coup là l'outil qui certes une
aiguille mais creuse trajet en fils
l'attrait ce que j'ai coupé dans
l'aiguillé et je fais passer voyez au
niveau du coeur et je fais passer
l'aiguillé dans le tour précédent opus
et j'ai presque à prestidigitation mais
regardez où je pose machinalement le
sécateur voyait la table elle est creusé
il ya la forme du secteur non on est
content c'est là elle a vu des dizaines
d'amateurs
alors vous allez vous allez profiter de
mon siège je vais m'en sortir bien vrai
dire j'ai un problème je voudrais avoir
bien compris pour ça mais on va faire on
va le faire tranquille parce que bon
c'est la tournée de tourner un petit peu
oui en fait se tourner voilà c'est tout
en tentant non voilà me guider la tresse
super super un autre tour impeccable
vous revenez la régulier
il ya donc déjà régulier aujourd'hui de
sonel 901 secondaire 3 2 et 2,2 et le 2
paf
est-ce que tu as une idée du nombre de
semaines c'est-à-dire des stars et du
café en italie cédric valmy le père
apparent mais c'est une production c'est
une toute petite au petit de production
mais il faut penser que cette table
l'ascendant au plus de 100 ans et c'est
le temps qui a fait que l'usure aux
quotidiennes c'est impressionnant parce
que à une période où il faisait jusqu'à
900 paiera dans la journée là à ce que
vous vous rendez compte 900 me perdre
dans la journée pensez nous sommes
entrés à ce qu'on fait jean jacques et
donc l'héritier d'une longue tradition
dans le pays basque pendant des
décennies tout le monde à porter des
espadrilles mais avec la concurrence des
marques ses chaussures ont pris un sacré
coup de vieux
dans les années 80 et 90 elle était même
carrément ringarde
rappelez-vous ce sketch des nuls en
espadrilles on avait un balcon on a les
ampoules ont dans ce disque on en
espérer
sa vue des pieds en espagne à cause de
cette mauvaise presse
l'entreprise a connu des jours sombres
l'argent ne rentre plus jean-jacques ne
peut plus payer ses dix ouvrière
et il se retrouve seul dans son grand
atelier mais aujourd'hui tout va mieux
les affaires ont repris depuis une
dizaine d'années les espadrilles sont
devenus furieusement tendance
en france il s'en vendrait chaque année
5 à 6 millions de paires la moitié
seraient fabriqués dans l'hexagone
jean-jacques a particulièrement la cote
car ses espadrilles sont made in pays
basque et le côté traditionnel
c'est ce que recherchent les clients
comme diane tell venus spécialement pour
commander une paire
je serai capitaine
à tours
et blanc toutes ces matières un peu
l'airé ça c'est très joli aussi mais ça
c'est pas traditionnels c'est très
traditionnel c'est la stratégie portée
picasso c'est la cuillère et cette
étoile elle est hissé à saint palais
alors ce ça c'est un truc taupin lors ce
qui me plaît dans les espadrilles en
général et dans ses espadrilles en
particulier c'est le travail de
l'artiste en le travail traditionnel
travailler à la malle ce travail raffiné
ce sont des métiers qui doivent se
transmettre et la meilleure façon pour
nous de favoriser ou dans tout cas
encourager cette transmission
c'est de les emmener à travers le monde
tout le monde veut des espadrilles
jean-jacques en a même fabriqué pour le
prince de monaco
pour répondre à cette nouvelle demande
jean-jacques doit fabriquer entre 60 et
80 paires par jour
pour l'aider il pète 12 couturière qui
travaillent à domicile et qui pour nous
et on va mettre le mouleur là dedans il
faut qu on le mettra deux ans il faut
que vous vous débrouillez à le faire
rentrer c'est à dire une aubryste
alors oui mais on va le faire en douceur
la métamorphose à la métamorphose
voilà comment ça lui même un petit peu
oui
les compressions ça va chauffer et
honorine yvelines
oui c'est ce qu'ils fabulent un seul jc
de mètres au milieu
voici le centre est là et après on avait
la main gauche à vous allez fermer le
tiroir allez-y
ah c'est pas un truc de ouf voilà c'est
bon non non laisser faire ou à laisser
fermer la vaudoise
voilà ouvrez la super menteur
voyez si au cours de la vie ici voilà ce
matin peuvent en soit voilà dans les
trous
mais trop c'est trop 3
vous devez y est magnifique de jeu wii
en fait l'entreprise ne peut pas
produire plus jean-jacques doit
régulièrement refuser des clients qu'ils
renvoient vers l'un des cinq autres
fabricants de mauléon il ya de la place
pour tout le monde fuit ont chacun
développé dans sa gamme développe des
produits différents on n'est pas
concurrent l'air on est complémentaire à
ses concurrents si on arrivait à dire ça
c'est souvent dans notre monde - nucci
mais l'évidence utilisés non c'est pas
dans un esprit de domination tu as toi
tu ne veux pas faire disparaître des
cinq copains montés autour de la
rigolote ouais si je l'entends et je
pense que c'est le seul échange et de
réagir pareil le cas de très marquant
chez lui c'est le fait de vivre sans
pression et ça cet esprit de compétition
permanente dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons cet esprit de concurrence
effroyable que nous livrons jour et nuit
qui détruit nos vies il m'a dit c'est à
l'armée
là c'est pour vivre partir de ce moment
là pourquoi allez faut plus chercher
plus si jean-jacques ne se fait pas de
souci c'est qu'il ne reste plus qu'une
vingtaine de fabricants en france et il
est le dernier à concevoir ses
espadrilles de a à z
ainsi c'est le seul à faire lui même ses
semelles la panne au collage le
caoutchouc il va aller pénétrer dans
toutes les fibres de la presse regarder
méthode est prévu nation c'est cheyrou à
la perfection il faut bien étaler le
temps du jeu les tables
voilà très bien j'aime être un peu plus
un peu derrière ce sont des endroits
sensibles super classe était
excellemment on va faire la même chose
de bien se rappeler ce qu'on a mis là
parce que l'on fait une période on a mis
en place il faut faire rentrer larry
rossy voilà il faut on doit noter guinée
il faut quand même garder la semaine
quels sont vos talents nationaux ben
voilà on va taper au milieu et le bas et
c'est là qu'on a ça sortait un colonel a
vu ce soir
imaginez que ce savant qui marche après
avec voilà je le pousse voilà été on va
lui envoyer la vapeur là et là
maintenant votre et c'est parti voilà
que notre mauvaise série mais il faut se
garder en tête qu'il faut moins d'une
minute pour charger un moulin jeudi et
alors je regardais parce que c'est quand
même un sacré boulot et pourquoi tu
décidé de faire toi même les décibels la
mécanisation est un point essentiel de
la qualité de l'espadrille à et on a une
qualité d adhérence bon compte et ma
démarche c'est d'essayer de maîtriser sa
cela on le sent bien moi je dérape et
réalise ses 10 ans
les semaines fait sur place serviront à
fabriquer des espadrilles traditionnel
mais en plus comme les grands créateurs
jean jacques dessine d'autres modèles
bien plus élaborées semelles compensées
lacées décoration en tout genre il
s'inspire d'un carnet de tendances
une sorte de livre d'image à destination
des professionnels qui détaille les
modes de la saison suivante
sa dernière création des espadrilles en
pot détruites
c'est vraiment vrai pour les truites c
de la peau de frites mais pour voir les
vertes vallées vertes parce qu'elle
était d'accord
dorénavant de lui garder la balle c'est
pas joli non non ça fait sympa et on
salir sur les pointes alors l'appareil
on tapote comme ça pas publiés pour
qu'il y ait transfert de la colle sur
les 2 bastia
voilà alors maintenant c'est à vous bon
c'est à moi bien alors parlons peu mais
parlons bien donc déjà suis là je vais
te le mettre là donc je mesure de
présenter une fois oui parce que quand
ça je peux me tromper mais même s'il est
devenu un créateur tendance jean-jacques
n'a pas oublié les valeurs de
l'espadrille mais pourquoi tu travailles
avec la peau de truites pour que calais
la région supérieur quelle est la raison
en fait là aussi c'est quand même si une
recherche d'optimiser c'est à dire que
mon copain a qui rêvent les truites
il ya deux il ya deux ans il ajouté
c'est peau parce qu'il n'y avait pas
d'utilité notre démarche c'est en fait
de valoriser un produit qui étaient
jetés pour nous toute récupération est
importante parce que bon on a l'esprit
des espadrilles c'est ça c'est utiliser
les choses à fond parce que l'on laisse
patrie elle a été créée par pour un
besoin par des gens nécessiteux c'était
pas pour faire du business ou pour faire
la mode
les gens étaient nécessiteux ils ont
créé ce produit avait des matériaux ils
ont trouvé sur place alors penses tu vas
chercher des jaunes du sparte pour faire
la presse tu coures les ruisseaux pour
prendre 500 g de gens pour faire une
paire de semaines
tu vas pas injecté 30 g ça peut toujours
servir on peut leur travail et leur
présente
si tu un peu de mémoire tous les 20 ans
c'est cyclique la mode va revenir et
donc va te ramener des idées que tu as
bendaoud et produisent 20 heures juste
voilà il faut laisser faire l'otan quoi
eh oui l'artisan garde tout tissu des
mots des vieilles bobines manuels
anciens son atelier a des airs de
caverne d'ali baba pour compléter sa
collection jean jacques se fournit chez
des artisans locaux
le jute et travailler au pays basque le
caoutchouc transformer à pompe lune et
son tissu est produit à 20km de
l'atelier à saint-palais bien quelques
bonjour monsieur la salle voilà ça y est
les toiles sont là super
y'a plus qu'à travailler et de qualité
et des qualités surtout on sait qu'on va
travailler avec quelqu'un de compétent
c'est comment il travaille on sait son
amour pour le métier aussi donc pour
nous c'est valorisant d'être une petite
part de ce produit authentique et c'est
beaucoup plus confortable on se connaît
bien et c'est vraiment confortable et
agréable et non mais c'est pourquoi tu
es à 1,6 et c'est important que ce soit
juste à quelques kilomètres de chez toi
parce que plutôt ailleurs aux fourneaux
ouais certainement mais j'ai pas cherché
ailleurs mais le fait d'être là sur
place c'est hyper confortable et on perd
on connait le produit moi je connais le
produit je travaillais toujours ce
produit l'éco consommation tout ça tous
ces termes en là en fait ce sont des
termes qui sont inventés actuellement ou
qui sont à la mode et qui sont pas
inventés puisqu'il existe mais que l'on
compte qu'ils sont à la mode
le développement durable le
développement durable je comprends pas
mais en fait ce sont les termes modernes
qui s'applique à des choses du quotidien
doit s'intégrer quand tu parles j'ai
l'impression
pardon sol et à bord
les gens qui étaient révolutionnaires
pacifiques gens que tu as
révolutionnaire de de porter de paire il
s'est lentement ne doit changer peut pas
continuer comme ça on peut pas s'en
prendre à la planète comme nous le
faisons se comporter comme des barbares
de plus en plus exigeants ça en nombre
revaz ont toutes leurs économies sur la
vente à l'achat d'armes très cher c'est
un dangereux cette affaire retour à
l'atelier jean jacques fait visiter ses
locaux à la demande et yvan des
espadrilles à prix d'usiné
bonjour mesdames un jour hélas ces
nouvelles ont fait j'étais embauché ce
matin je suis pas très bon voilà voilà
voilà
non non non non non non ici notre virée
rouaix ses sept jeux suivants
je passais tous bords enfin c'est mon
premier jour de boulot c'est notamment
là je sais pas celle là où j'irai pas
mal vous se trouve à son embauche un peu
fleuri centres de santé les miens le
tribunal moi je suis parce que ça n'a
aux yeux voilà à l'achever voit ici un
filet et à la bible alors voilà ici
alors vous pose bien le pied parce qu'il
faut que ça épouse
voilà c'est parti
alors bien sécher
je pars à chaud
jourdain
ça va trop vite
oui oui oui pour la vie c'est une
nouvelle vie qui démarre
parce que forcément avec les espadrilles
on touche pas terre quoi on démarre
d'une nouvelle vie bon la médaille j'en
tiens à saluer parce que ses gammes
épatant voilà bientôt la moitié de la
production de l'entreprise est vendu ici
le reste est envoyé à des boutiques dans
toute la france mais toi je me posais la
question du fabrique un produit sexuelle
pourquoi tu ne vends pas au supermarché
dont le fait de nos grandes surfaces
derrière une surface c'est rentré dans
le dans un commerce rapide et je vais
dire qui diminue un peu le volant du
produit par le par une présence du prix
et les gens qui rentrent dans ce dans ce
concept de vente se fragilise beaucoup
et nous en fait on préfère avoir dix
vingt trente clients plutôt que de se
faire accaparé le pays si ces libertés
vrai on a besoin la negra marraine
départ voilà parle dans l'esprit
jean-jacques expédie ses produits en
france mais aussi à l'autre bout du
monde
par exemple japon d'ailleurs il a fait
l'objet d'un reportage dans le magazine
d'une compagnie aérienne nippone
justement aujourd'hui il doit préparer
une commande pour une boutique située à
tokyo
et pourquoi les japonais adorent les
espadrilles mais il cherchait
actuellement ce qu'ils cherchent c'est
le côté profond du produit traditionnel
et là notre client reconnaît notamment
on voyait on a des pochettes que l'on
réservé à nos clients ici nos clients
qui viennent directement et il tient
absolument à ce que nous mettions des
pochettes pour vendre nos espadrilles
dans les pochettes
mais en fait vous voyez la pochette à
peine c'est ça alors est-ce que c'est
pas le côté naturel
moi je le souhaitais et très saine voilà
la spécificité la pureté partager pont
mai puis le tramway est une passion
alors amine passé on aurait dû les
signes et les causes des consignes et on
va bien c'est rien ça existe ça veut
dire que l'avenir n'est pas soutenir
n'est pas foutu dangereusement l'avenir
est en tête
et le plus beau c'est que les
espadrilles sont revenus à la mode même
dans le pays basque
quand je vois tu vois en fin d'année au
mois de septembre tu as des mamans qui
vient d'acheter des espadrilles pour les
lycéens et collégiens tarn à sa femme
avant ça on a connu de notre époque
il ya cinquante ans c'était pour moi
c'était mort quoi déjà le mot déjà à mon
époque
ça faisait un léger us de porter des
espadrilles et voir les jeunes
maintenant avec quelle ferveur est tout
à fait c'est super motivant pour que le
pays aille mieux
il faudrait beaucoup plus jacques je
vous mettais déjà 34 à chaque ville il y
en au petit déjà vous allez le sentir
passer
vous allez voir les mesures à la journée
est finie il est temps de se dire au
revoir et dont j'aimerais bien que vous
gardiez convenir rien cadeaux et
peut-être votre femme sera bien contente
lorsque vous ferez les brochettes autres
mais un rapport remis à peut-être lilas
il a il a gagné sa journée en raison
d'abus au sein du cube dans la vallée
des roses
c'était vraiment de continuation
exceptionnel on se reverra aller un bien
tant bio et non bio
une expérience qui a marqué dans la
seine je pense que les temps on venait
ou d ajaccio se lever un peu partout
parce que je crois à ce changement
demande comme il y en a eu d'autres
durant notre ère il reste cependant
toujours assez g de période de
mondialisation
à l'arrière